bootleg cab podcast man special guests
in here representing the east side of
Detroit cash kid let's get it grandson
what's the deal with you man come on
let's get right to it man come on man
uh-huh
[Music]
yeah let's get it RJ hey
there's a [__] hey
hey
[Music]
and she loyal with good thoughts she get
big Chanel God please send me your angel
we're gonna give him hell first I ran up
100 like the NFL then I threw a quarter
in the bank like I said wish him well
she want my whole heart but it's only
dick for sale trying to hang with a pig
like Tinkerbell my price being higher
because I don't took many L's my little
shooter let a pop caught him can't kill
went a long way one no shortcuts [__]
got low cheese like a shirt bus yeah
bobbing in the pool with like four [__]
trying to rob me he's a fool like the
fourth month the chain coming sticks
like some nunchucks wrong with a cold
[__] she's warmed up we might never
speak again once this door shut no I
keep a check on me like the ore Ducks
broke as hell you never got no plays
this is fourth punch Get It from Her
Mama baby girl a natural born [__] yeah
100 guns on the tour bus with the court
for ripping off like a warm-up yeah
trying to rip me off they got me turned
up [__] poor as [__] trying to any up
with short blunts they hit the guns
though the mama snitched for the reward
bucks I've seen it all someone asked me
why it ain't no more trust [__] hey hey
right out the gate Ludacris in this big
foreign
about
biscuit on my waist Fresh Prince of
Bel-Air I took the Smith to the bank got
annoyed set the hit while I was fishing
on a date through my phone in the water
I'm off instant for the day taking Snaps
in New Orleans like I'm kicking for the
Saints in New York with that Striker
like I'm pitching for the Yankees ref
Carl three seconds he was chilling then
got painted the third of the space put
the [__] to get some braces yeah [__]
the [__] asleep so the bishop quit
complaining gold on me like a sand froze
up like on the ranch [__] hey [__]
read them bad boys I know it's breakfast
we're just dripping with some Altoids
gamer text now goofy [__] think I got
Android I'm on my Peaks and kills trying
to duck the alphabet boys [__] hold up
hey who the [__] is dude in two seconds
from the smack boy left my mark on the
mic like bad boys now I got the big head
like a Bratz toy [__]
yo I can keep going keep going all right
come on keep going man hey come on hey
you said taking Snaps into New Orleans
kicker
man yeah man
bro
yeah appreciate you that was crazy
take that [__] too
hey I know you just watched a new
freestyle guess what we're dropping them
every week sometimes more than once a
week Jesus we've been dropping a lot
lately uh shout out to LRG don't forget
go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off at checkout you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg and save 30
off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week